on considère aujourd'hui que la vie
privée est assez mal traités sur
internet voilà aujourd'hui c'est
l'horreur excuse moi j'arrête pas de
jouer d'être génial
[Musique]
un nouveau but dans les locaux de cointe
compte c'est le moteur de recherche
français qui respecte votre vie privée
il ya quelques instants la conférence de
presse parce que quand équipe le view de
pro2i co c'est un début une première
collaboration en tout cas entre les deux
mains intéressant vous est derrière nous
et la presse quelques instants juste la
lancement view de pro compte alors ce
qui est intéressant c'est que la
question de vie privée la problématique
de vie privée surtout qui est vraiment
hyper hyper hyper hyper important si
vous n'y êtes pas sensibilisés ça y est
vraiment de vous sensibiliser à la
problématique
voilà six mois cette grande salle qui
vident je conseille vraiment de vous
sensibiliser à la pratique et c'est un
sujet qui est vraiment hyper important
alors justement ce qui est cool c'est
d'essayer de comprendre pourquoi est ce
que oui qu collabore avec compte sur
cette question du moteur de recherche
il ya peu un sujet hyper intéressant que
ce que je propose c'est qu'on aille
directement discuté avec les principaux
intéressés et vous verrez les choses
vachement sur table
bonjour est ce que je peux vous essayez
vous présentez vous voulez 2 ok super
voix je m'appelle tristan nitot je
travaille chez cointe où je suis
vice-président et les gens qui me
connaissent souvent parce qu'avant je
travaillais chez mozilla dont j'étais
président pour mozilla europe
moi je suis jeune et engagé travail chez
ricoh je suis
c'est au donc en charge de tous les
fonctions back office est basé à
marseille
ok alors aujourd'hui on est là pour un
événement un peu exceptionnel on a deux
marques qui se rejoignent de bases
françaises cotées courante des moteurs
de recherche qui respecte votre vie
privée
d'un côté on a weak ok constructeur
français qu'on connaît aussi beaucoup
quelle est l'idée de travailler ensemble
c'est un besoin c'est une nécessité
c'est quoi en fait alors moi je peux
répondre pour compte l'a beaucoup de
jeunes en particulier enfin de gens et
de jeunes en particulier 58 % utilisent
principalement le smartphone pour aller
sur internet mais où on est un moteur de
recherche on est français on est
respectueux de la vie privée mais avant
tout on est un moteur de recherche donc
si tu veux avoir être le moteur de
recherche par défaut sur un smartphone
de cette qualité là d'un rapport qualité
prix pareil dont 20 c'est génial parce
que ça nous donne accès en fait
facilement sans que les gens et à
changer quoi que ce soit ils ont accès
un compte
et en plus ce qui est complètement
nouveau sur android leur vie privée elle
est protégé quand ils font des
recherches sur le web
mais quand donc voilà ce que nous ça
nous amène ça nous amène accès à des
gens qui sont conscients du besoin de
protéger leur vie privée
donc d'un côté on a un besoin de
protéger la vie privée et côté
constructeurs de smartphones
c'est l'idée est justement de travailler
avec compte alors pour nous oui qu donc
le premier le premier soit c'était
justement d'offrir ce choix aux
utilisateurs de choisir le moteur de
recherche qu'ils veulent dans le
smartphone puisque ce que
ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure un peu
plus de la moitié des jeunes utilisent
le moteur de recherche par le smartphone
donc ça offre une alternative à
avec avec compte donc c'est un choix
pour nous également will go on considère
aujourd'hui que la vie privée est assez
mal traités sur internet
alors là aujourd'hui c'est l'horreur
jusqu'où moi j'arrête pas de jouer
d'être génial d'avoir pressé machin tout
brillant tout neuf tout nickel tout beau
et super efficace et oui alors
évidemment pourquoi parce que en fait
aujourd'hui l'internet il est financé
par la publicité ciblée les annonceurs
plutôt les grandes plateformes voulez
tout savoir sur toi c'est pour ça que
google il t'offre gmail etc
a quito google maps pour te suivra
l'activité tant gps tout ce qui te donne
en fait comme l'application gratuite en
fait c'est pour pomper des données et
pour tout savoir sur toi et pour donner
la publicité ciblée
alors évidemment en terme de fuites de
données personnelles c'est juste
monstrueux c'est pour ça qu'on a monté
comptes qui lui ne par exemple tu vois
tu vas sur compte points comme il n'ya
pas de bannière à accepter les coups qui
parce qu'on met pas cookies du tout tu
peux vérifier dans ton navigateur il n'y
a pas de coups qui donc parce que je
pense que l'internet c'est quelque chose
de génial messi c'est aux dépens de
notre vie privée
eh ben ça pose un problème est justement
avec compte on démontre qu'on peut faire
des services qui marche très bien et qui
te pompe pas tes données personnelles
est au contraire un yvon respecter comme
contre ta vie privée alors là c'est
important la question du business model
parce que comme tu as devient
effectivement citer google qui est le
plus gros aujourd'hui eux il leur
business model c'est
devant le rideau n'est en tout cas de
monétiser monétiser les données comment
vous fonctionnez vous je compte
eh bien nous aussi on met de la
publicité mais c'est la publicité pas
ciblé c'est de la publicité contextuelle
la différence c'est que la publicité
elle vient du contexte tu vas sur
compoint comme tu tapes vélo où elle va
on sait que j'ai une personne on sait
pas si t'es un homme ou une femme sait
pas combien tu gagnes non c'est que tu
t'intéresses à cet instant t au vélo et
donc nous on regarde nos annonceurs qui
ont acheté le mot clé vélo et on affiche
la publicité sur le pour des accessoires
de vélo dont tu peux avoir un amazon où
tu peux avoir un décathlon où tu peux
avoir un magasin de vélos et qui passe
de la pub et et voilà mais personne ne
sait qui tu es tu as de la publicité
mais sans qu'elle soit si les centres
quand pages de données personnelles
d'accord ok alors du côté de survie
qu'aux smartphones qui est super après
la question je me posais sais c'est le
smartphone de l'année dernière qui est
aussi un excellent smartphone pourquoi
pas le faire sur le nouveau clip de we
cote cette année donc ça c'est un début
louis a décidé de le faire pour pouvoir
qu'ils soient disponibles là tout de
suite après alors on envisager d'autres
sur d'autres modèles effectivement rue
d'accord ok ok ok chouette question
contenait côté de compte aujourd'hui au
micro de moi peut-être d'autres
smartphones d'autres fabricants ah ben
moi j'espère bien en fait on parle déjà
avec beaucoup de fabricants
oui causé les premiers et alors ça pour
ça vraiment on les félicite et j'espère
qu'ils sont en train de lancer la
tendance et que d'autres vont les suivre
pour offrir des smartphones avec contre
respectueux de la vie privée auquel
souhaite n'auront se ressent de la
vraiment sûr du des français et franco
français en route et même du sud
ils sont marseille et nous
historiquement on est ni si tu vois et
même notre patron est et corse
donc en fait voilà c'est c'est la france
et c'est le meilleur c'est la france et
le sud
et puis évidemment l'ensemble est la
dernière question comment c'est fait
c'est l'idée de se rapprocher comme ça
c'est que ou diffusion on sait que tu as
besoin il y avait une nécessité est ce
que c'est une soirée trop arrosée à il
faut qu'on passe ensemble quelque part
entre nice et marseille dans une
paillote ne sera très discret sur ce
genre de discussions ouais il y avait il
y avait un besoin bien dégoûté de
chirico on se dit allez on est ce qu'on
a on va pas dire on
est ce qu'on a besoin de quoi entre 70
et philosophique se dire effectivement
on a envie d'aller dans ce sens là c'est
quoi l'idée de base d'aller travailler à
les compter dessus
l'idée c'est donc d'offrir cette
alternative aux consommateurs pour
répondre aussi à leurs attentes puisque
c'est un sujet de la protection des
données personnelles est quelque chose
de plus en plus sensible et donc c'est
d'offrir cette alternative ce choix aux
anneaux aux utilisateurs les gens
violents du vol quoi ouais génial et oui
qu était le plus rapide quoi c'est super
génial génial et d'animaux la
progression de comptes en france je m'en
rends pas compte du volume en fait eh
ben ça marche super bien aujourd'hui on
est 41e sites français c'est en forte
progression
on gagne des parts de marché tout le
temps c'est vraiment on a une croissance
de dingue c
[Musique]
voilà pour cette petite vidéo pour vous
parler de compte de huit cause cette
collaboration qui est très intéressante
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en bar
en bas là juste en dessous en
commentaire est ce que vous trouvez que
ça a un sens justement alors ne dirais
pas que le respect de votre vie privée
n'a pas de sens ou alors vous
surprendrez réellement mais est ce que
vous trouvez ça a un sens que oui qu
saliha compte pour que ce soit un moteur
de recherche natif vous marquez tout ça
est derrière vous allez voir la soirée
qui m'a son plein un consensus autour
des bords en verre et dites moi ce que
vous en pensez vous invite à visionner
ma playlist par là où par là qui parle
des nouveaux smartphones de la coupe du
monde ce genre de choses voilà vous
embrasse à de macao